you don't think I see you looking at my
little sister hmm don't think I know what
you want I know the opportunity before
you seems like the last you'll ever have
but you must not speak to me like I'm a
child I only want what do you want tell
me I don't need trust any longer I don't want
it and I don't have room for it you were too
young to be so and you what you familiar
will you betray her again Jorah the Andal
will you betray her again never okay I
have no interest in slaves a man cannot
make love to property you can use an
extra sword you're the queensguard
Ser Barristan your place is by the Queen
if we are truly her loyal servants we'll
do whatever needs to be done no matter the
cost no matter our pride and Daario naharis
Jorah the Andal you here see our queen
she's in a good mood you don't approve it's
not a question of approval was the question
of trust you neither approve nor trust why would
I um as a cell sorter I trust you Daario naharis
killed his captains and dumped their heads at
your feet when he grew tired of their commands
how could you ever have faith in a man like
that I could never have faith in a man like
Daario let me speak with her in private you'll
never be alone with her again I have loved you
[Music] love can you say that to me any other
man and I would have him executed but you I do
not want you in my city dead or alive please
don't ever presume to touch me again or speak
my name as you cannot have him by your side
when you do remove Serge aura from the city
isn't it frustrating one thing someone who
doesn't want you back of course for this
you're a romantic I admire that sometimes I look
at you and I think so that's what I'll be like
when I grow old I'll Queen she's wild you know
don't let a size fool you it's hard enough for
me and I mean young man you I don't think your
heart could take it must make you angry that
our queen chose me it's be sad you'll disappoint
it before long she'll move on we sailed together
[Music]